pam réunion à aix-les-bains de
spécialistes européens de la greffe de
moelle osseuse pour faire face au manque
de donneurs les médecins ont imaginé de
nouvelles techniques notamment la greffe
de cellules du cordon ombilical des
nouveau nés
reportage en daniel flaysakier nathalie
gallet pendant de longues semaines
claude barberi va tenter de vivre le
plus normalement possible dans cette
enceinte stérile il vient de subir un
traitement très lourd destiné à éliminer
les cellules leucémiques qui ont envahi
son sens et sa moelle osseuse depuis 24
heures sa vie a pris un tournant
on lui a transfusé des cellules saines
pour tenter de le guérir
et cette greffe n'est pas banal la
donneuse et new yorkaise et à sa
naissance on a coupé son cordon
ombilical maison lieu de le jeter
on a recueilli le sang de l'artère et
d'éveil les cellules du sang de cordon
sont et c'est une extrêmement vaillante
qui vont assurer une prise rapide de la
greffe et qui en plus ont pour intérêt
de ne pas être rejetés facilement par
l'organisme parce que sur le plan
immunologique elles le sont comme on dit
naïve elles n'ont pas eu encore
connaissance de toutes les agressions
extérieures
c'est en fait c'est un peu il expliqué
mais c'est très émouvant
dans le sens de fabrice de savoir que
c'est cet amour olic qui peuvent
souffler reekoye sais c'est c'est
quelque chose de merveilleux c'est
ce sens renaître si vous voulez avantage
de la méthode donneur et receveur n'ont
plus besoin d'être strictement
compatibles comme dans le cas d'une
greffe de moelle
inconvénient il ya très peu de cellules
dans chaque prélèvement
aussi les chercheurs essayent de
multiplier par cinq ou dix le nombre de
cellules disponibles
on espère ainsi constitué des banques de
sang de cordon non seulement pour
traiter les cancers mais aussi des
maladies sévères comme la polyarthrite
rhumatoïde
il manque une seule chose actuellement
l'argent